all right i'm a crewmate
i will fix engines
fuel and no fuel engines that's what i'm
gonna do
fuel fuel and fuel fuel
almost too easy upper engine fuel
fuel fuel fuel
lights lights fuel
fuel almost too easy
oh i can see uh blower engine
lower engines okay
what happens if you complete all the
tasks
upper oh what the what the frick that
scared me i got the dead body
i found one mark have
but i found a dead body it was in the uh
it was in the
the security left outside security is
where it was yep
that's where it was i tried to get bob's
bob was in the reactor tried his
attention he didn't care
am i the only one who went to the right
side of the map
to go to the lights they're not admin i
was in the cockpit but i like to go to
the lights
who literally just said i tried to get
bob and then
switched it to i tried to get bob's
attention
no no i'm literally you can ask bob i've
been doing no no no no no no
that's suspicious oh yeah we're going to
freudian around here
he's going to point fingers at me the
entire time so i've just been dancing
with bob
i tried to get bob tyler you i don't um
he who casts the first stone i'm gonna
i'm gonna stick by tyler again
you weren't in the electrical room you
were near a gas tank
i was not yeah with that whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa i was in there flipping
the light switches while someone was
[ __ ] around we were flip-flopping
those light switches for forever
two other people were in there doing
tasks at the top whenever bob and i
walked up there who was flicking lines
with you
i'm suspicious i don't know i saw ryan
and wade and cockpit
doing stuff yeah i was in cockpit then i
went over to do lights you were three
people were flipping switches
that must have been i was the only one
in cockpit for like half that round
it was early it was the very beginning
i'm watching you it could be me i could
be the killer
blah blah blah i'm gonna murder you i'm
gonna
murder you murdering
murder by murdering well that's probably
not good
i'm watching i'm him
i'm watching them while i'm watching
them faking me out
i see i see i see i see i see how
i oh i did it
okay got it i'm watching you i'm
watching him
like a hawk like hawk oh
[ __ ] all right hi mark i was hurt by
tyler the whole time he didn't do a
thing he even uh helped me put out the
uh
put in the uh out the oxygen i'm
committing put out the oxygen
can i ask where the body was oh yes yes
i who called this meeting i'm willing to
disclose some information
yes please so i just saw everything that
shield said being true
chilled was dancing in front of bob and
they were down in admin i was down there
i walked up i left them ten seconds
later in the top left
right before the med bay there lied
oh god uh which from the met there ryan
i think it was ryan
yeah oh oh oh
[Music]
[ __ ] well since that was overall it was
it was freaking
chill i told you it was chill
i told you it's the way he wanted that
it was jim
i will say chill did say i was trying to
get bob and then corrected to get bob's
attention he did not
all right crew it's time
let's do this let's do this
i think i fixed the wiring that's the
good stuff
oh i don't trust that well i don't trust
that at all unless they're doing the
same thing
that i was just doing maybe
i have a slight problem ryan was here
and there was someone else and i don't
know who it was but ryan looked like i
caught him with his hand in the [ __ ]
cookie jar cause he said wait
ryan ryan what were you doing right i'm
going to lay all my cards on the table
i walked into navigation saw jack dead
on the floor
thought to myself not this [ __ ] again
walked out
ryan ran past me into navigation and
then
follow me down into a store right and
you run like a little bit of a circle
what
are you doing what was i doing what were
you doing
i have the map open you guys know this
when i'm running those that have
played with me before i have the map
open
we're glancing over a big a big issue
bob why didn't you report the body
i didn't want to i don't know
[Music]
he's actually doing his tasks in the
correct spot that's why i'm gonna escape
thank you
okay yeah otherwise i wouldn't wait wait
we're skipping for now like
i ain't just brutally murdered i'm
voting it's either ryan or bob so i
picked one
i voted bob wow
oh all these people trying to uh make
things happen and and you know what it's
just
it's just ridiculous it's just
ridiculous it's ridiculous and
when it's redonkulous you know you just
you just gotta keep going you know you
gotta keep going
got it you can't stop going until you
keep on going and then
you make the go and you do the going
and that's it okay
oh i don't know if it was lag but
chilled [ __ ] appeared next to me in
navigation
or it was a vent that pad
yeah if he just shows up it's gonna be
lag can i just love it real quick i say
thank you even then he tries to blame me
i was doing that three circle thing
where you're trying to press the the
timing on the button
and you're moving over to do what uh
whatever the middle one is
i mean i know there's the wires to the
left i forget which one is the middle
i believe ryan uh i thought he was
moving over to kill me but i i don't
think he was i think he was actually
doing the circle that leaves
the only person who killed stinky jack
had to be if
bob and ryan were both in the room or
killer vented are we going with the
theory of the camera
right now you're pointing so many
fingers and leading
i found the body okay do we have any
other information other than bob did
anyone see
anyone suspicious for the rest of the
round no i just saw
chilled and bob hanging out in the
cockpit i saw
absolutely [ __ ] all people i was in med
band reactor last round
tyler and i were in yeah
i think it's all three of them there's
three imposters i've actually tried to
die because i feel bad for sean being
like the only
dead one for a few rounds so i'm
literally just like i'm just gonna do
the tasks and
if i die i die at this point so i'm not
really worried about it
everyone's pointing fingers they forget
we got a ship to run here
we gotta get to whatever our destination
is actually now i understand how this
fueling thing works i gotta feel up the
the can and then i get to go uh oh i'm
dead
i knew it i knew it hello
well i'm dead oh hi who killed you uh
teal yeah i was tyler tyler was like
running from the whole hallway i'm like
yeah
it's him it's him and then he stabbed me
and it was him people just love my
throat they just
love going oh and maybe it may even wait
uh starting to learn the game but
obviously like i said at the beginning
of this
some people are not going to like the
way i play this game because i never
play these games correctly
i just don't i don't like it the way it
is so i make it fun for myself
that's how i do too bad so sad
a boo hoo to you
that was laggy
disconnect i don't even know what
happens
i couldn't hear anything i'm pretty sure
we know the truth
i hope this is right otherwise it's hang
me next round
you guys suck because there was no
evidence against me and also
discord literally crashed
[Applause]
so shut up oh my god i love democracy
i really do oh yeah i i actually was
deaf so i didn't know what happened
i got screwed so hard because my discord
literally you can't tell you killed all
of us
we're your victims tyler it was i did
not kill everyone
you were in the security room and they
stabbed me right next to you and you
were still there
i didn't see you on the camera no i was
dead right next to your body
i know and then i was like oh [ __ ] you
said teal which is wade
yeah yeah yeah oh what a trick
i'm still trying to learn wade's ways no
you never will even wade doesn't know
what he's doing
i did i do so well on killing nobody saw
me do anything and i still get screwed
every single time
it really was you had discord die on you
yeah i can't control that
you didn't show up to your trial i mean
what do you want
my discord literally just stopped
working you could ask my chest
you get one trial they got a lot of
points man yeah
maybe you should make sure your internet
works properly i have
gigabit it's damn discord okay yeah well
no one has
so wait uh wade found me that's good
that's good
glad wade found you um i don't know
exactly where the body was
i was in storage heading down to
electrical and the lights are out
all right well let's see where this play
hopefully everyone's getting their tasks
done get your chat's done wade
come on man yeah wait you know me i'm
doing them most of them
damn it what a [ __ ] i
know what the i'm sorry the the z is
like oh this is before
reactor i deactivated the reactor i was
the one who did it
markiplier are you doing oh gee i keep
calling full name mark are you doing the
uh
all the tasks i'm trying to yeah i think
i've completed okay i like how you say
you're calling him this whole name
this is his birth name yeah it's on my
birth certificate my mom calls me that
actually so
that's nice it is pretty nice thank you
wait is this really all the tasks
yeah i i'm done i'm going to quickly be
right back i [ __ ] up the sample thing
it's the first time i've ever gotten to
the end of it and i picked the wrong oh
you picked the wrong color
well i didn't know what to click on and
then for some reason i clicked the wrong
button at the bottom like a dumb
it's okay wait is too many people to
kill well i locked and we know tess will
get done because wade is the devil so
he's not holding it up i mean if if wade
was smart he would be by bob right now
guys we got five seconds i locked
everyone i think we're just gonna need
one more after years right
yes which one is it oh
i just got i just got murdered by wade
yep
yeah did you have any more tasks you did
a lot of tasks i i finished my tests
okay you think ryan's the last one on
this one oh
and he has
yeah even i did my tasks wait hold on
who was the other imposter
that's that's why we finished with my
tasks
come on uh hell yeah
i'm gonna do my tasks so good fix wire
ring
okay med bay actually let me go med bay
i want to go med bay
med bay met press to start
okay go do something else
okay there's garbage in the cafeteria
a oh yeah there is
okay there's garbage in the storage okay
this game's fun
this game's dope
[Music]
nice no here got it
nailed it nailing it nailing it
nailing it nailing it oh no
not again god damn it what how hi
i am i just found chill's body in
security
oh and i saw once i saw mark he was down
he went towards electrical
he was in storage he went towards
electrical after doing the trash shoot
thing i was actually just waiting
for the body because i was about to go
in there
no body was discovered chilled
i think i can clear z and ryan doing
cards
i think i can clear tesh we we were both
running together too
i know that i was good i'm gonna give
myself the clue
we were fairly far away i don't feel
good about not voting for someone this
round but
are we all scared i feel really good
don't do your tasks
i'm pretty sure it's weird watch is it
shawn and ethan were watching i don't
[ __ ] know
is it thanks all right
i was uh i was stalking bob you know
just like playing a little
gonna dance on him as he's on the camera
he turns around slits my throat i'm like
oh
oh no reverse card okay yeah
i went into electrical and i was like
what are the odds that tyler is going to
be
you know again and oh the odds were very
good actually
i was i was telling uh because i saw you
pop into med bay with me and i'm like
i'll eat my hat if mark found the med
bay thing went to it did it and then
left i'm like there's no way he's he's
faking that and then
it turns out you're dead with me so yeah
that's good there would be no way
literally in no way would i ever get
that right
oh boy oh boy how that
looks tyler you want to explain yourself
why you just killed him at the trash
shoot
oh no no oh did you always
see it i literally saw the floor i was
running 202 as fast as i could
yeah after killing him
[Applause]
you know okay that eases the pressure
tyler who else did you kill i'm not
telling you
you really went with the your honor he
deserved it i mean
no bob's a baddie he's a baddie yeah i
thought so because i totally passed him
running away from the reactor and then
he like claimed he hadn't gone into
electrical and
he literally i was stalking him and he
turned around just killed me then went
back to his business i'm like oh
it was funny because i killed i killed a
good electric girl right
right apparently when he killed in uh
security yeah
it was a good double i went in there i
was like i can't beat him again i'm
willing to hedge my bets i've been
stalking him the whole time and then
boom head shot like just like ah okay
i've got you good ryan bob got you good
oh my god
i literally i was literally talking to
chat and saying oh i
i i'm always suspected of bob but i love
bob and then he stuck a knife in my back
that's what he does that's what he does
he does that well
what were you doing in reactor oh i was
doing simon says
okay did where did you go you just went
straight down after that
yeah i did simon says i walked out down
through the engine to
storage today okay well you were about
four meters from my body
what wait you went to do try the body
was just
above like just in the top engine right
next to the walkway down
oh well i wouldn't have seen it was it
in the hallway uh i basically walked out
down so unless it was out there i
wouldn't have seen it in the hallway
anyone else have any other information
i saw bob at trash chute right as the
body was found and i was waiting to see
if the bar would go up when he finished
and that's i saw ethan twice and i feel
like he should have killed me
yeah asteroids as he walks i'm trusting
jack at this point
all right so we down to vote for bob was
over there too
in my mind because i don't have a lot of
alibi but i was just doing stuff
oh no i'm with bob suspect i'm with bob
and tesh as well
bob's the common denominator we all
think sir yeah
so we'll go bob and then tesh if that
doesn't work out
or you ethan didn't speak up that very
first round
that was the only that's the only thing
tyler killed someone directly in front
of another person
he was not in my view range where i
killed
good [ __ ] good deserved it
all right i'm guessing this is a new map
that we're trying here
i have no idea if it is going to really
suck if i'm the imposter and it's a new
map because i will have no idea where
anything actually is
all right oh what is this what oh
what is this oh my god uh oh my god
okay what does that even mean what is i
don't know
i can't see i'm blind i don't know where
i'm
going i don't know what i'm doing i
don't know what is this
oh i thought i was gonna die if i went
in there what is this
is this something i have to do what is
that what
what okay i did that
what this doesn't make any sense
oh that's weird i don't trust that
what is any of this
what is what is any of this oh
this map is so confusing oh yeah agree
mark i've only played this map like once
you can open the doors as well they're
like little circuit breakers so if
someone locks you in there you could do
that just take the right button
yeah yeah take it away yep so z was
next to on to the left of the
communications just below the fence
for lights by that pylon thing wait what
went out there
if you orientation bottom bottom left or
middle left of the mouse i saw the
middle
and bottom left on the trash suit right
before i did trash
was it was it lights that went out and
had to be fixed it was yeah
yes i was in the middle of doing my
tasks i
my taskbar is closed so i didn't see
what it was i'm on the right i did the
telescope thingy
i will
just play dumb like me you'll be fine
i will say mark was just randomly
wandering around in office he could have
come from that way because he wasn't
doing anything
i walked by i was doing something it was
a weird
flippy thing it was a card and you flip
it and you scan it and i only that
wasn't
in the last one i don't show my
conscience
because he hasn't played the match
before so i trust margaret
who was that that accused me jacuzz who
did that
i think mark has just been watching my
videos wait no one watches your videos
all right uh okay this weird okay
there's two
over here why are we going over here
what is this all about
what is all this i need to go this way
i need to go this way i need to go this
what is this what oh
oh dee oh oh
hi bob oh no please don't be them
well interesting
you too huh who killed you uh bob and
chill
just watched it happen so basically yeah
they killed the
other bad person he killed me
immediately it was
very unfortunate because i was coming
out of decontamination i didn't know
what that was and i was like ah
that's actually like one of the worst
places to kill someone because you can
just get trapped in there
apparently no i was coming out of it and
well it was because they were both there
i think
it's just like all right okay now you
can do your tasks in peace
yeah and that's what i really like about
this game is actually the tasks i i
i find that games like this i don't like
uh so but the tasks are super nice but
you don't like because what it's
complicated or no no no it's just
complicated i just don't like this type
of game
uh okay emergency i thought i died
it's bob i saw him kill tyler on cam
up by the rocket boom all right
i don't know enough about this game to
know where the cameras can see so that's
fine
but wade was with you you could have
blamed it on him
huh no listen if you guys want to eject
me
or kill me i didn't see what's happening
i don't want to get a
oh my god wade were you listening to
nothing that just happened
no i was not i just want to die because
i have the the ship steering wheel
so he said he could blame you if he
wanted to yeah
it was you who are we voting for i voted
for myself
are you like the new patrick this time
around are you talking
are you weight throwing yes
i don't want to do the spinning wheels
kill me
man bob i i thought i was safe because
like oh yeah two people
oh this'll be great yeah i'll be totally
fine
although although if you're in a group
it doesn't necessarily mean you're safe
because
the imposters can just turn out the
lights and then just cause a bunch of
chaos by killing someone in front of a
bunch of people and no one will really
know for sure
yeah that's true that's all true you
speak the truth i
accidentally went into the room that is
decontamination not knowing
what it was and i saw bob waiting
outside the door and i'm like
i trust him he's a good man look
i was on security cams to the left i saw
jack was on the right he did the right
react or the right reactors and i went
to security cameras
and i saw tesh and ryan you guys were
lingering around the left one for a long
time i don't know what else you were
doing over there anyway you said you
went to security cameras but you went
down right
now i went to the i went to the right
reactor i saw you up there you did that
then i went left towards the security
camera no no it's chilled he went down
and right he went down from where the
right reactor is
where was the body well hold on where
was the body found well hi guys i called
this meeting as i found little blue boys
bottom half and i only knew it was him
from the blue butt cheeks
where is the body found he's to the he's
like right in the middle
by the top you came straight down from
the starting zone he's like right there
above whatever that first building that
clears me then jack because if you're
saying that i went down
i'm telling you i went left changed the
topic entirely and clear well not clear
chilled but change it entirely
remember first round how i said i had
information i thought ryan was faking
the fueling task
but i wasn't right because
i don't know what he wanted to say to me
i i'm pretty sure i saw him do asteroids
you were standing right there next to me
i do remember you watching me i was kind
of worried but
we thought guys have we voted anyone
good bad off yet okay
so the reaction the reactor is on the
right child went right it went
straight down if i went straight down i
did the fueling again
you could have gotten left
how is the same guy who walks over dead
bodies and past
murders that are actually happening in
front of him the guy who's on the camera
is [ __ ] super sleuthing me this round
[Laughter]
would it would it be better or worse if
i was to do something such as that
if you happily accomplished something
that you had no idea what you were even
doing i wouldn't even
oh my gosh it would be a joy
wow
i'm so upset
[Laughter]
i literally called it and told you he
went the wrong direction of where he
said and no one believed me
you said that no one watches my videos
i've been crying for the past 10 minutes
okay cool all right
my objective is to not be the first one
dead
this is probably not a good one to do
right now
but i'm doing it anyway just because i
don't have any strategy going into this
so anything that's gonna be like smart
plays is not what you should expect from
me
oh i thought i thought i [ __ ] died oh
my god
you scared me so much yeah i thought you
killed me
so here's what jesus christ that turfed
the [ __ ] out of him i saw
ryan killed chilled and then ryan
tripped and fell on his own knife
he was really desperate for revenge so i
saw child's body
i made up for rest but i'm pretty sure
it's what happened i was with
bob like the entire time there were dead
bodies his body
was to the left of the telescope in the
top right you mean the
laboratory top right to the left of the
telescope i don't know or not
not like that's yeah it's like next to
the school that's where you came from
sean came from who i was in the specimen
room and sean came down
from from lab into specimen room yeah
but i didn't see anything
no one was with me wait yeah that lab is
the best i think
i think what we're overlooking is the
circumstances of these
apparent double homicide if wade
saw them both die that means two of the
imposters were in the same area at the
same time what are the others
i only found child's body what are the
others
it would have to be five people in the
same area for wade to be an innocent
that means circumstances wade and bob
were by me
both at the same time so i think bob and
wade are clear
no no i think i like the time anyway
i'm guilty all right i don't know who to
vote for
but wade's gonna vote for himself you
don't skip them because i'm skipping
i didn't see anyone if i die think about
what i said
oh
oh well not a lot of people are oh what
that
someone is someone doing this i feel
like someone's doing that
why are the doors all closed bob and
wade i don't trust that for a second i
don't trust that for a second
it's very quiet
well i found tyler's body down by the
trash chute
i came to do lights everybody was there
and on the way down past it i found his
body
well i also saw you and tyler down there
before the lights
yeah and i walked up to do the lights
and then when i came back down and now
he's dead
and you're attraction that's very funny
because
i did the lights twice i did him twice i
fixed him twice
why were you doing it bob watched me
shower
i'm tasha's throwing a lot of
accusations i'm
throwing a very direct accusation at
sean
i literally fixed the lights
twice they went out yeah more more than
one person can fix lights at the same
time it's
the imposter can fix lights well the
posture can also take down lights
i'm pointing my finger my finger has
been pointed
and that wade and that bob for good
measure who should i point my finger at
i'm voting because he keeps trying to
accuse me and he's somehow in
all the exact same locations as the dead
bodies so he claims i was not in the
location i saw you entering the location
was everyone voting for
shawn ortega we're going to go through
your gut way
what no really flip a coin wade wait
a minute wait just vote
fairly certain it's like wade and jack
interesting why are both of my things in
here
oh
i knew it i declared moral victory
because i knew it argument was so flawed
though no it wasn't
look if i have only small pieces of
evidence to go off of
and dead to rights right from the start
yeah
and for some reason all it took for wade
to say no it's not tesh was like you you
guys just said oh it has to be tesh then
and then wayne just
throws the game no we're voting this way
and i just followed the group man
that first round i did tell wade to
follow his heart
it's okay wait wait it's okay we got the
moral victory
go crazy go crew we got the moral
victory
[Music]
bye